so when you go to sleep at night if
you're someone who hasn't had any sleep
deprivation you're very normal sleep
pattern what we tend to see is that in
adults they go to bed and they start off
by going into the deeper stages of sleep
so the deeper stages of sleep are really
those times of quiescence you're really
restoring your body and we have a few
different stages of sleep so you have
sleep stage 1 2 and then 3/4 one is a
little bit lighter stage of the quiet
non REM sleep and then 3 4 is really
deep deep sleep and what you want is you
actually want a number of you want to go
through all these stages throughout the
night so people only focus on getting
the deep sleep but in reality we spend
almost 60% of the night in this stage to
sleep so we go through in the beginning
of the night we go into the really deep
stages of sleep and we actually cycle
through so when you go down to the deep
stage then you go back up and you
actually come into something called REM
sleep which is after about 90 minutes so
when you're in limb sleep your brain is
very active your body's quiet but your
brain is really processing a lot of
things a lot of emotions we dream the
most right and sleep and then you go
back down into deep stages and so on so
forth and you cycle throughout so that
you do about 5 to 6 cycles throughout
the night and we spend more time in REM
later on in the night than we do earlier
on that's why people tend to remember
their dreams in the morning a little bit
better and if earlier in the night when
you're really in a lot of deep sleep
if someone wakes you or the phone rings
or something you're really confused
really even if it's an hour or two after
you fell sick because you're in such a
deep sleep at that point
well sleep tense - we actually don't
know the function of sleep all that well
yet but sleep is a time of quiescence in
the brain when you're in the more deeper
stages of sleep REM sleep your body is
quiet but your mind is actually very
active so it's a time when your body and
your brain is restoring itself it's
repairing any cell damage that happened
during the day it's really repairing
like I said repairing your body but also
helps with digestion helps with memory
it has a lot of things that it's doing
while you're asleep
so sleep deprivation and sometimes an
insomnia which is a little bit of a
different form but just getting a lack
of sleep can lead to a number of
different decrements so decrements and
attention and concentration being able
to learn more efficiently that's just
not as good
also there's motor vehicle accidents
workplace accidents we see that a lot
workplace actions with people who are
sleep deprived or people who work shifts
and they don't get the right amount of
sleep during the day or at night and
also there's a new line of research
showing that people who don't get enough
sleep their body doesn't metabolize as
well and so they actually it leads to
weight gain so if you're not getting
enough sleep you might have difficulty
losing weight